pueden los aliados bloquear la mayor
exportación de rusia puede el mundo
prescindir del petróleo ruso atentos
[Música]
se habla mucho del gas natural por la
altísima dependencia que de él tiene
europa pero lo cierto es que rusia es
sobre todo y ante todo un enorme
exportador de petróleo para que os
hagáis una idea en 2021 rusia exportó
petróleo crudo y derivados del petróleo
gasolinas diesel queroseno semi
refinados etcétera etcétera por un valor
aproximado de 180 mil millones de
dólares esto supone más de tres veces
sus exportaciones de gas natural por las
que ingreso a unos 55 mil millones de
dólares
[Música]
durante el 2021 cada día del año rusia
exportó de media a aproximadamente unos
4 millones y medio de barriles de crudo
y en torno a 3 millones de barriles de
productos refinados unas cantidades que
la situaron como el segundo mayor
exportador del mundo de oro negro tan
sólo por detrás de arabia saudi el 70%
de todas sus exportaciones de crudo por
cierto fueron a parar a europa y eeuu
[Música]
y amigos amigas este es el petróleo que
eeuu ha puesto en su objetivo para
terminar de doblegar a la maltrecha
economía rusa y destacó esto porque
sobre este punto suele haber mucha
confusión en los medios de comunicación
a veces se dice que bloquear o embargar
el petróleo ruso implicaría encontrar
una fuente alternativa capaz de
proporcionarle al mundo cerca de 11
millones de barriles diarios pero eso no
es cierto
[Música]
rusia produce en torno a los 11 millones
de barriles de petróleo cada día pero
una buena parte del mismo lo usa para
consumo interno además para asestar un
duro golpe a su economía ni siquiera
haría falta sustituir todas sus
exportaciones de petróleo bastaría con
que una parte de ellas se quedara fuera
del mercado tener en cuenta que casi el
40 por ciento de todos los ingresos del
gobierno ruso dependen directamente de
las exportaciones de petróleo y de gas
[Música]
en cualquier caso amigos la cuestión es
que ahora la guerra lo ha cambiado todo
y es que veréis inicialmente las
sanciones que se han impuesto a rusia
excluyen al sector energético incluyendo
la operativa bancaria que permite llevar
a cabo la compraventa
este es por ejemplo el caso de gazprom
bank el tercer prestamista del país que
además se encarga de gestionar las
transacciones de gazprom el gigante del
gas ruso pues bien este banco no ha sido
excluido del sistema swift ni tampoco se
le han restringido las operaciones con
dólares
pero ojo porque pese a ello muchos
bancos refinerías petroleras o armadores
navieros han reaccionado a la invasión y
a las consiguientes sanciones
internacionales rechazando llevar a cabo
cualquier operativa con entidades rusas
ya sea por riesgo reputacional por el
miedo a que las sanciones les terminen
salpicando oa que las sanciones vayan
más allá y no les permitan cobrar su
minuta el caso es que la invasión de
ucrania convirtió al petróleo ruso en
algo tóxico esto es amigos exactamente
lo que explica por ejemplo noticias como
esta 8 de marzo de 2022 cell dejará de
comprar petróleo y gas ruso y aún más
según datos de varias consultoras
energéticas tras desatarse la tormenta
militar cerca del 70% del petróleo ruso
empezó a tener problemas para encontrar
comprador
la consecuencia tras invadir ucrania las
exportaciones rusas de petróleo podrían
haberse desplomado durante las primeras
semanas de marzo un 35 por ciento en el
caso del crudo y cerca de un 50 por
ciento en el caso de los productos
procesados hablamos de aproximadamente
17 y 13 millones de barriles diarios
menos además el rechazo al petróleo ruso
ha hecho que éste tenga que venderse más
barato por ejemplo se calcula que el
petróleo de los urales se está
intentando colocar en el mercado con
descuentos de más de 18 dólares por
barril
y ahí no termina todo de continuar la
guerra y el ciclo de sanciones el riesgo
real para rusia según el instituto de
estudios energéticos de la universidad
de oxford es que sus exportaciones se
reduzcan aún más según los cálculos de
este centro de investigación podríamos
estar hablando de entre 3 2 y 4 millones
de barriles por día es decir
aproximadamente el 50% de las
exportaciones teniendo en cuenta tanto
el petróleo crudo como los productos
procesados eso supondría un golpe
durísimo para la economía rusa e incluso
podría obligar a rusia ante la falta de
capacidad de almacenamiento a tener que
reducir la producción cerrando pozos lo
que podría llegar a ser devastador no es
nada fácil volver a explotar un pozo
cerrado
claro que también puede ocurrir que ante
la falta de suministro global rusia
finalmente consiga colocar todo su
petróleo aunque sea aplicando fuertes
descuentos en ese caso digamos que el
golpe sería importante pero no tanto
precisamente por eso los aliados y sobre
todo el gobierno de eeuu está como loco
por buscar la forma de incrementar lo
más rápidamente posible la producción
mundial de petróleo y esto esto es lo
que por ejemplo explica titulares como
este la casa blanca le dice a la
industria petrolera que necesitamos más
a medida que los precios del combustible
se disparan el secretario de energía
dice que la nación está en pie de guerra
mientras que colombia advierte sobre la
aproximación a venezuela queridos amigos
amigas del gobierno de joe biden está
intentando por todos los medios
encontrar más petróleo porque encontrar
un nuevo suministro abundante podría
permitirles a los aliados sacar adelante
la madre de todas las sanciones un
embargo petrolero sobre rusia un embargo
un bloqueo que aunque se limitará al
petróleo crudo y por ejemplo no a los
productos procesados supondría enviar a
rusia de vuelta a la edad media sería
algo así como un jaque mate para el
régimen de vladimir putin ahora bien la
pregunta es cómo cree la casa blanca que
puede conseguir ese nuevo suministro de
petróleo que es realmente algo factible
qué consecuencias podría tener pues bien
en seguida lo vamos a ver pero antes
antes tenemos que darle un tirón de
orejas a la política económica de yo
bailé y amigos amigas tras la invasión
de ucrania el presidente de los eeuu ha
tenido que dar un volantazo tan grande
que está haciendo derrapar toda su
política energética atentos
[Música]
el mayor error estratégico de vaivén
acelerar la transición energética hacia
fuentes limpias esta fue la promesa
electoral que llevó a yubá idem a
colocar a la industria petrolera en el
centro de su diana y no no penséis que
esta vez las promesas se quedaron en los
mítines de campaña en absoluto nada más
llegar a la casa blanca you buy the end
se puso manos a la obra y empezó a
emitir una tras otra órdenes ejecutivas
contra la industria del petróleo
norteamericana de esta forma el nuevo
presidente quería dejar claro que un
nuevo tiempo había llegado a washington
y no olvidéis que hablamos del productor
de crudo más importante del mundo así
que poca broma
[Música]
el 20 de enero joe biden firmó un
decreto que detuvo las operaciones para
explotar el petróleo del refugio
nacional de vida silvestre del ártico
canceló la autorización del oleoducto
keystone xl para traer más petróleo y
más barato de canadá y ordenó a las
agencias del gobierno estudiar nuevas
reglas para frenar el consumo y las
emisiones de petróleo un poco más tarde
el 27 de enero otra orden ejecutiva
estableció una moratoria que prohíbe los
nuevos contratos de arrendamiento de
tierras y aguas federales para buscar y
explotar petróleo y ojo porque casi el
25 por ciento de toda la producción
actual y potencial norteamericana
depende de yacimientos en tierras
federales o en altamar
y aún más también ordenó a el secretario
de interior estudiar cómo incrementar
las regalías y los impuestos a las
empresas petroleras al tiempo que otros
departamentos están intentando reducir
el capital y la financiación disponible
para llevar a cabo nuevas inversiones en
combustibles fósiles y claros y recortar
los dólares disponibles también los
encarece para colmo desde entonces
también se ha ralentizado la concesión
de permisos para llevar a cabo nuevas
explotaciones o construir nuevos
oleoductos o carreteras de acceso a los
yacimientos por ejemplo cuando les
compete las autoridades federales tardan
unos 140 días en aprobar un permiso de
perforación las autoridades dejadas en
cambio tardan sólo 2
amigos amigas todo este paquete de
medidas combinadas no solo redujo el
suministro potencial de crudo sino que
sobre todo envió un mensaje alto y claro
a la industria norteamericana no merece
la pena invertir grandes cantidades de
dinero en el sector petrolero porque el
gobierno lo va a castigar y ojo porque
actualmente eeuu está produciendo en
torno a los 11,6 millones de
barriles/día esto supone aproximadamente
un millón y medio de barriles menos que
la producción pre cobit es decir que si
la administración baile no hubiera
puesto palos en las ruedas es probable
que hoy nos estuviéramos enfrentando a
precios del petróleo mucho más reducidos
recordad que ese millón y medio de
barriles equivale a más del 30 por
ciento de todas las exportaciones de
petróleo crudo de rusia y claro eso es
lo que ha hecho que la casa blanca de
todo un volantazo fijaos
eeuu presión a la industria del fracking
para que haga lo que sea necesario para
aliviar la crisis del petróleo pero
dicho esto la pregunta que tenemos que
hacernos es se puede compensar el
petróleo ruso como pretende exactamente
la administración vaya en conseguirlo
pues bien atentos
[Música]
como excluir al petróleo ruso
y esto amigos es la pregunta del millón
la pregunta que podría enviar de forma
definitiva al traste todos los planes de
vladimir putin algo así como el golpe
final la casa blanca y el resto de
gobiernos aliados quieren ahora lograr
un suministro de petróleo tan abundante
que puedan poner sobre la mesa el
embargo petrolero contra toda rusia pero
como demonios lograrlo realmente es algo
que se puede hacer pues bien para
intentar conseguirlo podemos encontrar
una estrategia con cuatro campos de
actuación que los gobiernos aliados han
puesto sobre la mesa y el primero de
ellos tiene que ver precisamente con la
industria del fracking
[Música]
y amigos a pesar de todos los palos que
la casa blanca ha puesto a la industria
del petróleo lo cierto es que la caída
de la producción se debe sobre todo a la
propia industria y es que veréis la
caída de los precios entre el 2015 y el
2019 y luego encima de coronavirus fue
demoledor para las empresas del fracking
norteamericanas empresas que perdieron
decenas y decenas de miles de millones y
de hecho muchas de ellas terminaron
quebrando así que ahora la mayoría están
centradas en invertir menos y aprovechar
los precios de petróleo para hacer caja
repartir dividendos y recomprar acciones
y aunque los altísimos precios del
petróleo que estamos viendo tras la
agresión rusa podrían ya de por sí
resultar demasiado tentadores hay una
pregunta que tenemos que hacernos que
podría hacer el gobierno de estados
unidos para estimular aún más la
producción pues bien podrían empezar por
cambiar su discurso agilizar los
permisos facilitar financiación barata
para nuevos proyectos y también derogar
la ley jones
[Música]
la ley jones establece que sólo los
barcos con pabellón de eeuu pueden mover
mercancías entre los puertos del país
esto hace que en muchos casos resulte
más barato importar petróleo extranjero
que comprar petróleo nacional por
ejemplo según la comisión de energía de
california importar petróleo desde el
golfo de méjico puede resultar un
67% más caro que traerlo desde países
extranjeros
con todas estas medidas la producción de
petróleo norteamericana podría
incrementarse en más de un millón de
barriles al día durante el 2022 y por
supuesto no se trata solo de eeuu
boris johnson abre la puerta al fracking
en respuesta a la guerra de ucrania el
primer ministro analiza todas las
opciones mientras se prepara para
elaborar una nueva estrategia energética
luego en segundo lugar tenemos a los
viejos socios de siempre
[Música]
amigos eeuu quieren largarse de oriente
medio pero al final siempre termina
volviendo parece casi una maldición pero
aquí estamos de nuevo si hablamos del
petróleo tenemos que hablar sí o sí de
oriente medio y sobre todo de dos países
arabia saudita y emiratos árabes estos
países son de los pocos productores del
mundo que invierten dinero en tener
mucho petróleo almacenado y una
producción de reserva es decir que son
capaces de incrementar sus exportaciones
muy rápido si se produce algún suceso
inesperado fijaos por ejemplo en este
recuadro
[Música]
tal y como podéis ver estos cuatro
países tienen la capacidad de
incrementar su producción en 4 millones
de barriles cada día prácticamente el
equivalente a todas las exportaciones de
rusia así que incluso si utilizaran el
50 por ciento de esta capacidad las
cosas se podrían poner muy pero que muy
difíciles para moscú solo la opep puede
ayudar a occidente a reemplazar el
petróleo ruso el problema es que las
relaciones actuales entre la casa blanca
y el gobierno de arabia saudita son más
bien malas pero en cualquier caso eso es
en lo que ahora están trabajando y de
momento parece que emiratos ha empezado
a responder 10 de marzo los emiratos
árabes unidos- empujan a los aliados de
la opep para aumentar la producción de
petróleo y luego en tercer lugar están
los enemigos acérrimos con los que ahora
washington parece querer buscar una
tregua estoy hablando sobre todo de irán
y venezuela amigos washington se ha
puesto manos a la obra a alcanzar una
tregua con irán y levantar algunas de
las sanciones que pesan sobre este país
podría inyectar un montón de oferta en
el mercado según el ministro de petróleo
irán puede alcanzar la máxima producción
de petróleo dos meses después de
alcanzarse un acuerdo nuclear hablamos
aproximadamente de 1,4 millones de
barriles de petróleo más por día
no
en el caso de venezuela esto puede
resultar incluso más complicado la
infraestructura petrolera venezolana
está tan dañada y deteriorada que
difícilmente podrían incrementar su
producción en medio millón de barriles a
un año vista pero entre unos y otros el
cálculo de la casa blanca es claro
hablamos de entre un millón y medio y
dos millones de barriles al día
[Música]
a ver no es algo sencillo y
probablemente que queréis que os diga
terminen nada pero seguro seguro que lo
entendéis el trasfondo de las noticias y
el intento de acercamiento de washington
a teherán y caracas ya os hemos dicho
que la invasión de ucrania lo ha
cambiado todo ahora en washington
entienden que moscú supone una amenaza
mucho muchísimo mayor y que sobre ella
sobre la que tienen que concentrar toda
su atención pero amigos aún nos queda la
cuarta posibilidad
[Música]
y es que veréis prácticamente todos los
países tienen reservas estratégicas de
petróleo para tirar de ellas y por
cualquier motivo el suministro falla o
se tensiona demasiado eeuu y sus aliados
acuerdan liberar 60 millones de barriles
de petróleo de sus reservas a medida que
la invasión rusa de ucrania provoca un
aumento de los precios pues bien las
reservas estratégicas de eeuu que son
las más grandes del mundo ascienden
actualmente a unos 575 millones de
barriles de esta forma en eeuu y los
países aliados podrían ir mucho más allá
y hacer un uso sin precedentes de estas
reservas para colocar en el mercado 100
o 150 millones de barriles o incluso más
para reducir así la tensión hasta que
las nuevas fuentes de suministro que
hemos visto fueran capaces de bombear
más y más petróleo si sería algo
arriesgado pero además de aliviar el
suministro actual la medida podría ir
ligada al compromiso de reponer las
reservas durante los próximos años lo
que garantizaría un plus de demanda que
estimularía aún más la inversión de la
industria no sé quizás sea un riesgo que
haya que asumir
en fin estas son las cuatro vías de
actuación que los gobiernos aliados
están estudiando para sustituir el
petróleo ruso y junto a ellos hay otro
factor que puede resultar trascendental
amigos la débil situación de la economía
china a la guerra en ucrania las
sanciones y sobre todo el incremento de
precio de las materias primas y la
energía pueden ralentizar la economía
global eso es algo que podría traducirse
en que el consumo de petróleo fuera
menor del esperado y viera cierto margen
pero dicho esto la última pregunta que
podemos hacernos es por qué bloquear el
petróleo ruso
pues veréis la economía rusa se está
tambaleando como consecuencia de las
sanciones internacionales imponer ahora
un embargo petrolero incluso aunque esté
fuera parcial o no afectar a los
productos refinados podría ser todo un
jaque mate por eso en washington no duda
en reconocer que están trabajando en
esta vía y ojo porque en el kremlin
también lo saben y por eso tratan de
meter miedo con declaraciones como ésta
está absolutamente claro que un rechazo
del petróleo ruso tendría consecuencias
catastróficas para el mercado global el
aumento de los precios sería
impredecible serían 300 dólares por
barril sino más sea como sea los números
dicen que sustituir el petróleo ruso es
posible aunque hubiera que hacerlo
progresivamente claro que de conseguirlo
estaríamos ante un mercado muy pero que
muy tensionado lo que significa que de
continuar así las cosas tendremos la
gasolina por las nubes un buen tiempo
aunque seguramente no tanto como amenaza
de moscú
gran bretaña eliminará gradualmente las
importaciones del petróleo ruso para
finales de 2022 he hecho esto seguro que
muchos estáis pensando pero enrique qué
pasa con china qué papel puede jugar
este país pues bien próximamente
publicaremos dos vídeos donde contaremos
qué papel está jugando china y kepa
puede llegar a tener así que no olviden
suscribirse a visual política y darle a
la campanita para estar atento a estos
nuevos vídeos y ahora la pregunta es
lograr a los aliados encontrar una
alternativa al petróleo ruso veremos
finalmente un embargo petrolero pues
bien déjanos por aquí abajo en tus
comentarios y abramos debate y ahora si
éste yo te resultó interesante no
olvides darle al botón de like una vez
más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]